all right let's keep the show moving
with a guy who has appeared on The Late
Late Show with Craig Ferguson and
performed with The Groundlings here's
Ryan Sickler
Thanks
that was electric everybody feeling keep
bringing that Thunder I'll see if I can
handle it oh man you guys got a bear
with me man I was driving here tonight
and uh I'm a little shook up man I was
sitting in the middle lane at this
stoplight and I heard these tire starts
skidding behind me and I looked up my
rearview it was the dude right behind me
he's ever having you before right man
my stomach dropped my adrenaline started
pumping I gripped a steering wheel I was
like please Jesus look this guy hit me I
need this I got bills to pay man I can
get 16 out of this one maybe 22 with a
good lawyer
you know whiplash runs in my family I'm
not asking you for much I just want to
be this intersections winning lotto
ticket because I do not do the work
thing well you ever lies so much on a
resume that when they ask you something
you're like it says that
my objective was to own a bakery you
start panicking saying stuff that doesn
t make any sense at all man you're late
that's probably a cut and paste there
right there man
you know how word is and you got people
to just make up their own jobs you know
like the public restroom attendant I
still don't get the philosophy behind
having a grown man in the bathroom
selling candy and gum and mints that is
filthy in a public restroom that is
disgusting if you want to have your
buddy's house and hit a jar of skittles
sitting on the back of the toilet are
you eating any of them hell no right
well for whatever reason that's
acceptable in a public restroom and I
don't know about any of you in here
tonight in New York but I have never
rushed into a restroom in any kind of
emergency like oh my god oh man I don't
think I'm gonna make it oh my god is
that a Twix I'm gonna go ahead and give
me a Twix I went out with this girl last
week and uh went back to my place and
things heated up a little you know and
she looked me dead in my face she was so
serious she said can you give me a
platonic massage can you platonically my
balls can't you do that cuz if you can
do that I'm gonna give you a seaweed
wrap in here tonight I got some kelp I
keep out in my toolshed for just such an
occasion it's looking like tonight's
your lucky night I got a friend of mine
it tells me if I want guaranteed sex I
should just get a prostitute he's like I
know what you're gonna say but if you
wear a condom you don't have to worry
about getting a disease I'm gonna be
honest with you all right getting a
disease is not what I'm worried about
okay it doesn't concern me I'm concerned
with getting a new disease you know what
I mean something brand new no one's ever
heard about they don't have a test drug
out on the market yet cuz that's how my
luck is all right if I have sex with a
prostitute one time I wind up with a
combination of the worse two things on
this planet and then I got to go back
and see my doctor my doctor be like mr.
stickler you might want to have a seat
I'm gonna go and keep my gloves on for
this we uh we ran a battery of tests and
it appears you have Cades juice sake
aids the hell is that sound like a skin
rash I'm get ready to break out some
what is that ah it's the first time
we've ever seen this it appears to be a
deadly combination of cancer and AIDS we
figured it'd be dead by next Tuesday
from Kate for Kate
I have kids now I mean can you at least
have it after me or something I mean you
know what no we're gonna stick with
Kate's it took us a while to come up
with that oh my god Kate I'm telling you
now if you're sexually active we're all
on this thing together
alright you cannot be scared to ask
someone if they have something that you
need to know about that's what this girl
one night asked her straight to her face
you know you have any STDs or anything I
should be concerned with
Jesus yeah you know what it's in the
herpes family look like how like a first
cousin or like an outdoor cat how is it
how is it in the herpes family it's kind
of like herpes simplex you know what you
know it's the one that most people have
most people most people have knuckles
okay careers birthdays socks you're
gonna start with herpes we've got a
sales pitch is that and look I know that
sounds hypocritical come from some Iowa
caves but I'm not apologizing to anybody
all right
I am a cage survivor New York that's my
time of mine super thank you